bonjour à tous je m'appelle aux rats je
vais donc du beatbox la musique avec ma
bouche en fait mon métier c'est de faire
de la musique avec ma bouche et et je
suis pas tellement vous venu vous parler
de ça en fait je suis plutôt venu
raconter un vous parlez d'un
questionnement que j'ai à propos du
point commun qui existe entre un caillou
un gant et puis un satellite a priori
pas grand chose comme ça en fait
sauf que avec tout un tas de gens avec
qui je travaille des développeurs des
bidouilleurs des maker des ingénieurs
des techniciens du spectacle avec
lesquels ont créé tout un tas de
spectacles donc au sein de la compagnie
regagnent leur kerstrat ont créé tout un
tas d'outils qui me permette sur scène
de pouvoir enregistrer ma voix de
pouvoir la contrôler dans l'espace de
pouvoir jouer avec le dispositif
lumineux ou vidéo dans une salle de
spectacle au début on tombe vie de
boxeur assez vite quand alors déjà j'ai
commencé à faire des breaks la bouche
quand j'étais petit à peu près en même
temps que j'ai commencé à jouer aux jeux
vidéo et puis plus tard au collège j'ai
vu quelqu'un faire de la musique avec sa
bouche vraiment faire ds ont assez
souffert des rythmes tant que la mélodie
et là je me suis mis dans la douche dans
ma chance en salle de classe un peu tout
le temps jusqu'à ce que je finisse par
remonter sur scène et puis décidé d'en
faire mon métier
et quand j'ai commencé à en faire mon
métier justement joué assez rapidement
avec ses pédales pour les guitaristes
qui permettent de s'enregistrer en
direct de faire des boucles et puis de
créer des orchestrations alors qu'on est
tout seul c'était super intéressant
parce que justement je pouvais être
plusieurs
sauf que j'étais obligé de regarder mes
pieds comme ça et puis rester un endroit
particulier sur scène bref ça me coupe
est toute une partie de la relation avec
le public et avec les bidouilleurs les
développeurs avec lesquels je bosse et
ben on s'est mis à créer des outils un
peu plus adaptée qui me permettent
toujours de m'enregistrer mais en
détournant des manettes de jeux vidéo
des téléphones portables ou tout un tas
d'autres objets même créé des
contrôleurs qui me permettent
de bouger plus facilement sur ça nous
lance un truc dont je me suis pas mal
servi sur scène notamment au sein des
différentes expérimentations comme le
bionic orchestra donner des choses comme
ça
bonjour
m
cet effort pratiquants fait d'utiliser
la même chose avec laquelle je pouvais
envoyer des messages aux copains et puis
pouvoir enregistrer sur scène sauf que
justement sur scène
d'une part ça avec tous les bienfaits
que toutes les bonnes fonctionnalités
que j'y trouvais ça m'obligeait à
regarder un peu au creux de ma main en
permanence comme ça à me couper d'une
partie de la relation avec le spectateur
et puis en termes de poésie je pense que
pour vous tous ça reste un téléphone
portable
l'idée qui est donc apparue il ya trois
ans a été de se débarrasser de ce
téléphone pour créer un objet qui soit
plus adapté plus transparent plus
naturel et plus adapté à mes mouvements
et avec donc les geeks comme on les
appelle les développeurs de la compagnie
et puis et puis une structure qui se
trouvent ici à grenoble qui s'appelle
l'atelier art science est bon on s'est
mis à réfléchir sur un outil qui soit
plus adapté justement à ce que je
voulais faire un spectacle il se trouve
qu'on signe à travailler sur bas sur un
gant en fait on sait on sait je suis pas
mal intéressé à qu'elle était déjà la
gestuelle que j'utilisais sur scène
j'avais un micro qui est un peu mon
instrument
et puis de l'autre côté j'avais tendance
à faire tout un tas de mouvement avec
avec la main et l'idée c'était de
réussir à se servir de la manière dont
je pouvais bouger la main pour pouvoir
contrôler les machines à distance sans
trop attendre je vous propose de voir un
peu ce que ça donne
nous
une
m
et
de vue
mais
oui
on a créé ce gant pour un spectacle qui
s'appelle bionique orchestra 2.0 qui a
joué pour la première fois ici à
grenoble avec lequel on continue de
faire de la route
et puis ce grand m'a apporté tout un tas
de choses déjà effectivement j'avais
tout un tapage est illustratif pour
pouvoir quand je faisais du beatbox tout
simplement
et puis et puis là c'est l'outil qu'a
commencé à apporter toute une nouvelle
gestuelle
alors je suis toujours pas de danseur
mais par contre je bouge de plus en plus
sur scène et tout le dialogue et toute
cette interaction qui s'est passé avec
avec le gant depuis qu'on l'a construit
est en train pas mal de me faire grandir
ça me questionne sur la relation que
peut entretenir avec ses machines en
fait je suis je fais de la musique à la
base qui a besoin de rien du tout de
fait la musique avec mon corps et puis
je m'intéresse à toutes ces machines
avec lesquels je peux d'efforts mais en
fait ce signal comme une matière sonore
comme une pâte à modeler que je peux
transformer je faisais des sons de
machines avec la bouche mais juste avec
la bouche
je commence à le passer dans les
machines et puis c'est tard il ya tout
un questionnement qui débarque derrière
ça et j'aime bien ramener ce
questionnement finalement à l'usagé
qu'on utile qu'on a de tous de
l'ensemble des technologies qu'on
utilise effectivement le caillou nous
permet de bâtir ou de détruire le camp
nous permettrait peut-être de contrôler
le monde pour moi déjà il me permet de
faire des spectacles et j'apprécie comme
ça quant au satellite
en attendant au lendemain du du
spectacle parce qu'on aime bien créer on
aime bien utiliser mon âme bien détourné
aussi quand je dis on c'est avec mes
acolytes
on s'est amusé à essayer de voir ce
qu'on pourrait faire d'autre avec son
gant il se trouve que à l'intérieur de
ce grand il ya toute une batterie de
différents capteurs
alors ces capteurs c'est aussi bien des
touches à chaque fois que j'appuie sur
l'un des interrupteurs de mon gant
j'envoie une commande à l'ordinateur
mais il ya aussi différents senseurs qui
permettent de connaître l'orientation de
la main ce qu'on appelle le yo pour la
boussole par exemple ou encore le pitch
si la main et vers le haut ou vers le
bas on a aussi ce qu'on appelle le
roll's le roulis si ma peau mais vers le
ciel ouvert le sol et quand on cumule
l'ensemble de ces contrôles là on crée
une infinité de gestuelle différentes
qui font qu'avec un seul bouton par
exemple j'ai accès à tout un tas de
pistes quand je joue finalement c'est
plein plein plein de possibilité de
dialoguer avec la machine et pouvoir
contrôler en spectacle du son de la
vidéo de la lumière mais j'espère dans
l'avenir avec ce genre d'outil tout un
tas d'autres choses
il se trouve que ça nous amuse pas mal
aussi d'imaginer ce genre de doughty
bains entre les mains de gens qui font
complètement d'autres choses imaginons
que on est par exemple un logiciel 3d
avec laquelle on fait de l' architecture
ou créer des jeux vidéo ou tout un tas
de de manipulation d'environnement
d'objets virtuels ou physiques
il suffit d'imaginer que ça devienne des
robots etc bref de manière assez
intuitive on a la possibilité avec ce
genre de d'outils de manipuler tout un
tas d'autres choses que ce qu'on fait
pendant le spectacle
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien me servir de
ce genre d'objets par exemple pour
expliciter un petit peu ce que je fais
avec le grand
plutôt que de tourner à me j aimerais
bien pouvoir vous montrer tout ce qu'on
fait avec ce vent va être vraiment très
cool on a quand même bossé sur deux
trois trucs qui pourrait vous servir en
fait dès aujourd'hui en fait en tout cas
que ce genre de doughty celui-ci ou un
autre permet de permet d'anticiper
simplement dans nos usages d'aujourd'hui
que ce soit dans le cadre d'une
conférence ted ou dans le cadre d'un
travail collaboratif ou simplement pour
manipuler les médias qu'on a qu'on a on
utilise à la maison imaginons que du
bout du doigt
ben on puisse mettre bas simplement à
faire des présentations alors chez en
train de vous parler un peu actuellement
de ce qui est en train de se passer
derrière
et puis finalement de passer au stade
suivant mais de rester avec vous voilà
ce genre d'utilisation que vous avez
assez vite perçu imaginons qu'on soit
sûr des médias un peu plus complexe et
que danser le coup d'une nous mettions à
lire cette vidéo où mme allard était là
lui l'arrêté pouvoir facilement gérer
les volumes
celle-ci ou encore l'accélération
on a tout un tas de trucs de cet ordre
là à faire contrôler finalement
l'ordinateur tous les jours ça nous
laisse percevoir pas mal de pas mal des
usages y en a un qui semble un peu fou
n'est peut-être pas si loin que ça
finalement d'envisager de pouvoir à
distance pouvoir intervenir avec des
robots lors d'une opération chirurgicale
par exemple bref trêve de deux démos
dans tous les sens il ya un des autres
usages sur lesquels on travaille tout de
même qui et comment ça va peut-être que
ça ne sert pas à tous dans la vie de
tous les jours mais peut-être que ça
peut être assez pratique pour des
personnes à mobilité réduite à
l'intérieur de la maison pour pouvoir de
manière assez simple contrôle et
l'environnement
de tous les jours on s'amuse à faire ça
pas mal finalement nous dans les salles
de spectacle mais c'est à peu près la
même chose c'est de l'électricité de la
lumière du son et des machines qui sont
derrière en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive
que ce soit ce gant ou tout un tas
d'autres choses c'était d'abord un rêve
c'était un rêve quand j'étais petit fin
c'était un rêve un peu pour nous tous
c'est d'avoir des objets comme ça qu'ils
deviennent aujourd'hui palpable parce
que la technologie devenue très
accessible parce que des communautés en
monde entier sont en train de développer
tout un tas d'outils de se réapproprier
les capteurs les techno etc
et je pense que on a tous cette
responsabilité par rapport à l' usage
qu'on fait des outils des techno par la
manière dont on peut les créer ou les
détourner de veiller à être constructif
à être créatifs
en tout cas nous on a décidé d'essayer
de le faire de manière poétique